that rally in Michigan the president
singled out a number of Democrats
especially the chairman of the House
Intelligence Committee little
pencil-neck Adam Schiff it's got the
smallest than his snake I've ever seen
he is not a long-ball hitter but I saw
him today well we don't really know
there could still have been some Russia
colors these are sick people Schiff
continues to accuse the president of
collusion with Russia now Republicans
are demanding that the california
congressman resign his chairmanship ed
O'Keefe is on capitol hill for us this
morning
edie good morning good morning Tony all
nine members nine Republican members of
the House Intelligence Committee are
calling on shift ago saying that they no
longer have confidence and his ability
to lead the panel Republican Mike
Conaway is leading the charge telling
ship yesterday that his continued claims
of collusion are quote incompatible with
his duties as the chairman of this
committee but Schiff fired back doubling
down on his claims and slamming
Republicans for denying the president's
alleged misconduct you might say that's
all okay you might say that's just what
you need to do to win but I don't think
it's okay
I think it's immoral I think it's
unethical
I think it's unpatriotic and yes I think
it's corrupt and evidence of collusion
Schiff and other Democrats still believe
the details in Mulder's report will be
bad for the president and they're gonna
do everything in their power to get the
report released now there's little that
members of the minority party can do to
oust a member of the majority party and
Schiff has no plans to resign and still
enjoy support of top Democrats including
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi Tony ed
adding to the intrigue on Capitol Hill
Jared Kushner the president's son-in-law
and one of his most senior advisors was
spotted there what's that about yeah we
don't entirely know why he was here but
we do know he was meeting with members
of the Senate Intelligence Committee
behind closed door
that panel is one of eight House and
Senate committees that continue to
investigate the president his businesses
and other Affairs more than anything
Custer's appearance is a reminder that
the investigations will continue even
after the malla reports conclusion
that's likely to complicate the
president's ability to work with
Democrats on anything else Tony thank
you very much we wish you a slow news
day today on this Friday